Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So I'm back on the set of the Paper Towns
movie, but over the last, like, 100 hours,
you and me and the Katherine and both of our
parents, uh, had norovirus, which is a virus
with this amazing superpower.
It can make a human being stay on or near
a toilet for, like, 12 to 24 hours.
Side-note, Hank: Why don't fictional characters
ever get sick?
Like why is Captain Ahab never like "Uuuh,
god, I've got the worst head cold and my throat
is very scratchy and I just want to stay in
my bunk but if I don't get up and try to find
the white whale, human beings will never learn
about nature's complete indifference to them,
so I guess I'll go to work."?
Anyway, while I was horrifically ill, I kept
on wondering who exactly was responsible for
my norovirus.
The thing is, Hank, you get norovirus almost
all the time by eating the poop of someone
who already has it.
Now, you only have to eat, like, .00001 grams
in order to get norovirus, but it is - I,
I want to emphasize this: someone else's poop.
Now, the clear Patient Zero in our family
is my daughter Alice; five days before Thanksgiving
she awoke from a nap and promptly vomited
all over her father, but I didn't get sick
then.
I mention this only because it leads to the
uncomfortable awareness that in all likelihood,
all of us have eaten the poop of everyone
we love.
I guess except if it's an Internet relationship.
Man, Internet friendships are the best!
The next time someone says to me, like "Oh,
your Internet friendships aren't real," I'll
be like, "Listen, if your construction of
reality involves necessarily eating poop,
then I'm going to stay right here in my land
of fiction."
Anyway, this poop eating business is great
stuff to think about when you're already extremely
queasy from norovirus, but the other thing
I kept thinking is that my beautiful one-year-old
daughter whose poop had started this whole
Thanksgiving family catastrophe was going
to be OK.
Like, norovirus is almost never fatal in kids
in the U.S., but around the world, it causes
more than 200,000 child deaths per year.
And most of those kids die for want of clean
water and oral re-hydration solution that
costs, like, 50 cents.
Alice got PediaLyte, that's the only difference
between, "Haha, what a funny family Thanksgiving
story," and the greatest personal disaster
I can imagine.
And whatever Alice grows up to do - whatever
any of us grow up to do - let's remember all
those times that everything rested on 50 cents
of PediaLyte or refrigerated penicillin or
access to clean water.
Now, of course, the actual process of getting
oral re-hydration solutions to the kids who
need it is, like everything else in global
health and poverty, fiendishly complicated,
but I don't think we should let that complexity
stand in our way or intimidate us.
Yes, it is hard, and yes, there are failures,
but organizations from Save the Children to
Water.org to countless local charities are
helping to decrease child mortality.
Hank, I am in no way grateful for my brush
with norovirus, but it's helpful to think
about as we head into Project for Awesome
season.
The world is a profoundly unjust place; it
always has been and I imagine it always will
be, but that doesn't absolve us of our responsibility
to look directly at problems even when they
are painful to look at and to try our best
to do something to decrease world suck.
So Hank: I'm sorry that you ate Alice's poop,
or possibly my poop; somebody's poop, anyway.
But here's to the hope of getting better,
both individually and as a species.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.